bientôt ce fils de chances de retrouver
noie le poisson fait swap live et
aujourd'hui on va se fait soit pas aidé
youtuber qu'est ce que ça donnerait si
j'étais par exemple squeeze phoenix ou
squeeze fait des vidéos ou squeeze
raconte aller là actuellement je suis
squeeze dream est là le feuilleton mille
ceci près moi là je peux tenir supra
yemin tout seul easy r d même le sourcil
j'arrive à bien le tenir pourquoi le
café et ils bruyant rien ça faisait pas
ses mots ce qui se passe ou pas quand
même arrête descendent là c'est vraiment
magnifique savoir avant est à base de
tomates hop et comme à chaque fois
oh oui la fonction mais j'avais oublié
ah non ça devrait bien marcher sur cette
photo je suis si prisé thüga qui y
voient un inconvénient
j'ai fusionna à lier d'aragon et leur
bonjour je suis squeeze qui a fusionné
avec cyprien qui était déguisé en
travesti est la bonne photo de profil
je vais voir ce que ça donne sur une
finition mais on dit ça va donner un
truc cool l'ofs les garçons veulent a
surpris dans le front comme ça c'est
tellement parfait soit bada gandhi non
mais la regarder leurs aînés comme ça
passe bien pour de vrais pour de vrais
je vais à quai le compte twitter dans 10
mn cette photo à la place et personne ne
remarquera est ce que vous préférez une
fille comme ça
ou une fille comme salut les gars sont
ok celle d'abord on est tous d'accord
pour dire écart entre fils à aiguines
donne un petit peu déformé mais au
masque c'est troublant et bien troublant
vraiment regardé comme pour là ça me
fait une sorte de grosse machine ici
regardez cette mâchoire la titanesque
quoi au fait tu fais des photos chelou
[ __ ] non c'est nul c'est encore plus
nuls ok maintenant squeeze fait des
vidéos photos de profil bas plus de
pixels s'y attendait rétro lui dans ces
troubles en osier vraiment barman pays
nombreux pour la deuxième tournée dans
toute la france
et si je prends son visage ça fait un
mec extrêmement chaude nouveaux abonnés
vous attends là c'est bien ici je lui
vole son visage la salle fera tout ça
fera jamais on est assez impossible
un mois avant dans les dîners de famille
j'étais toujours un peu un peu bizarre à
la proche de la dinde réalisations et
les nuls ça me met un visage trop gros
sur sa tête regardez quoique non il a
vraiment un gros visage sur cette note
n'a tuna tout à leuna tout j'espère que
ça à perdre et regardez comme je suis
jolie là d'un coup ça passe avec tous à
temps mais c'est incroyable regardez
appelez moi ce que vous y êtes 2.0 c'est
abusé comment ça va arriver à moga
regardez c'est un truc de fou masque
c'est que papa fouetter les grimaces
messieurs là oh non mais non mais non
mais si vous voulez mais l'application
des normes et l'application de respecte
de plus personne à la sava voilà c'est
fou on dirait natu kitty quitter ou à
temps la photo de plus loin voici te
plaît mais du coup on dirait 3 que
saluer
je suis tout petit il a tout mon visage
passe très très bien sûr ta tête
vraiment moi sur ma tête à moi ils
passent pas par contre sur toi et ça
donne vraiment un truc super mister vie
tient à aller non ça passe ça c'est un
[ __ ] de vampires avec l'appui tout
noir aulas il ya un début là il ya des
buts il ya un début des milk
bonjour c'est tout ceci n'arrive pas à
écouter mon visage à l'aller on a vu pas
mal aux 10 les victoires vont planter
les choux en chef on aurait dit vick est
là le fait la psychopathe
voilà tuant plus de grimaces voilà c'est
ça c'est de la barca enjoy phoenix tient
ou là c'est pas mal plus vous moquez
plus un bug vous moquez fao moi même
plus quoi on attend oui sur une j'adore
sur les photos bien officiel comme ça
bien propre c'est un peu de mal vraiment
c'est un bon show il y en a d'autres y
en aura bien d'autres où ça va aller ah
bah voilà m'appelle physique unique ctu
toucher à mon tour je te coupe un doigt
bâtard et je m'inclus ensuite pour
comment tu peux tout le recoudre
attendirent est vraiment enjoy phoenix
en sommes
et là on est vraiment un mec avec un
gros nez regardez ce gros crâne à la
photo originale et 100 fois mieux quoi
le blem quand c'est mon visage de ceux
là mais qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse c'est
incroyable regarder on tient cette
petite boîte en plastique c'est hyper
drôle aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans
cette vidéo si fanlo voilà j'ai rien de
plus à dire finalement à temps c'est
quoi cette photo des années 90 de six
panneaux quoi google mais toi jour bon
ça le fait mais je sais je sais la chose
est en tout cas faire
talk talk et marmottes j'accepte de
prendre ton vise cette photo null
j'accepte de prendre ton visage donc si
j'ai tout ce qu ils sur leur stone et
marmottes au silo bin on va à cette
belle barbe voilà on voit le skill dans
son regard
la coupe à portée de mains ok on finit
sur un p'tit djimy fait le con la
chanson qui va se passer un truc là et
ben non
salut je fais le bg et si je lui boys
les visages ont été totalement du média
même le grain de beauté qui s'est mis là
alors là j'en vois tout de suite mon cv
est celle qui lie merde oui mais
l'agencé a pas de cette notion faits
soient pleinement en ce fait soit pour
avec des tubes heures cette taxe vous a
plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas l'aimer
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas aussi à
m'envoyer vos meilleurs fait swaps
voilà sur twitter si vous ça vous fait
marrer j'ai aussi envie de me marrer à
l'insoutenable prochaine non merci
d'abord regardé petits bugs portez vous
bien tu as tout le monde pis